in other videos we've already introduced
the idea of an extraneous solution where
you go about solving an equation so
you're given an original equation and
you do a bunch of algebraic steps and
then you solve it and you get some
solutions and what we've seen especially
when we're dealing with radical
equations and especially some rational
equations
sometimes the solute all of the
solutions don't work for our original
equation and so the solutions that don't
work that don't work these are the ones
that we call extraneous what we're gonna
do in this video is get a little bit
deeper we're gonna look at some
extraneous solutions but really think
deeply about why they show up so let's
just give an example and this is one
that hopefully you're familiar with or
at least the idea of it you're familiar
with when you're dealing with radical
equations let's say you're trying to
solve 2x minus 1 is equal to the square
root of 8 minus X and I'm gonna go
quickly through it if this is unfamiliar
to you I encourage you to review solving
radical equations but we're gonna really
study why we get an extraneous solution
here so well actually why don't you
pause this video figure out what the
solutions are I'll give you a hint one
of them is going to be extraneous and
really think about why that extraneous
solution shows up all right now let's do
it together and just to go through the
steps that we've seen before for radical
equations you want to square both sides
of this so if you square the left-hand
side you'll get 4x minus 4x squared I
should say minus 4x plus 1 is equal to u
square the square root of 8 minus X
you're going to get just 8 minus X and
now let's see we can subtract 8 from
both sides and we can add X to both
sides so we just have 0 on the right
hand side and on the left hand side
we're going to get 4x squared minus 3x
minus 7 is equal to 0 so we have an
interesting quadratic here you could use
a quadratic formula but it looks like
this one might be factorable by grouping
we just have to think of two numbers
that when we add them so a plus B needs
to be equal to
negative three and a times B needs to be
equal to four times negative seven needs
to be equal to negative twenty-eight and
the obvious ones seem to be right in
front of us four and negative seven four
plus negative seven is equal to negative
three four times negative seven is equal
to negative twenty-eight so we can just
break this negative three up into our
negative three X up into a four X and a
negative seven x so let me do that so
you have four x squared and then I'm
just going to and this is just factoring
by grouping once again if this is
unfamiliar I encourage you to review
that on Khan Academy so we're going to
get plus 4x minus 7x notice these two
add up to negative 3x so I'm not
changing the equation really or the
value or what it's trying to express is
equal to 0 and in factoring by grouping
we can group these two together and then
we can group these two together and for
these first two we can factor out a 4x
and so you are going to get a 4x times X
plus 1 and in the second two we can
factor out a negative seven minus seven
times X plus one and all of that is
going to be equal to zero and then we
can factor out an X plus one and so
we're going to get X plus 1 times 4x
minus 7 so times 4x minus 7 is equal to
0 and once again this is just to get us
to a place where we can look at what the
solutions are so we can see that either
X plus 1 is going to be equal to 0 which
happens when X is equal to negative 1 or
4x minus 7 is equal to 0
which happens when 4x is equal to 7
which happens when X is equal to 7/4 so
we've got these two solutions and I
promised you that one of them would be
extraneous so let's try this first one x
equals negative 1 and remember when you
when you solve a radical equation like
this you want to substitute back in the
original equation to see whether they're
extraneous or not so when you substitute
x equals negative 1 back here you're
going to get 2 times negative 1 minus 1
is going to be equal
to the square root of eight minus
negative one and so on the left-hand
side you have negative two minus one
that is negative three and you get that
equaling the square root of nine the
principal root of nine and so you get
this weird result that three negative
three is equal to three which we know is
not the case and that's why we know this
is extraneous but as I promised why did
this happen and the key is to realize
that when you're doing algebraic
manipulation some operations are
reversible and some are not for example
if you say that a plus B is equal to C
and you want to solve for a and you
subtract B from both sides you are going
to get a is equal to C minus B and if
you were to start off with a is equal to
C minus B you could add B to both sides
you could add B to both sides to get
back to your original equation to get a
plus B is equal to C so this adding and
subtracting values from both sides that
is a reversible operation you can do it
in either in either direction but when
you're squaring things that is not true
and we did square right over here did we
to go from that first step to this step
we squared and what we'll see or what
you might already recognize is that
squaring is not reversible if I know
that a is equal to B and then I were to
square it we do know that a squared is
equal to B squared but if we go the
other way around if we know that a
squared is equal to B squared so if we
know that a squared is equal to B
squared do we know that it's always the
case that a is equal to B well I'll give
you an example that shows that that is
not always true we know that negative
two squared is equal to two squared but
negative two is not equal to two so
that's what we did here we squared at
this step and it's not reversible and we
were able to deduce a bunch of stuff and
then we got all the way to the point
that's saying okay X is equal to
negative one or X is equal to 7/4 but
it's not always the case that when x
equals negative one that we can reverse
all the way back to the service equation
and that 2x minus one
is equal to the square root of 8 minus x
and the two places where this is
important when you're dealing with
algebra the two obvious places are when
you're doing with radical equations
because you're doing that squaring step
and that squaring step is not reversible
the other case is when you are dealing
with multiplying both sides by a
variable and to understand that if we
know that a is equal to B but then we
were to multiply both sides of this
equation times X and so we'll get X a is
equal to X B that could be true but is
the other way around necessarily true if
we know that X a is equal to X B is it
always the case that a is equal to B
well I'll give you an example where that
isn't the case what happens when X is
equal to 0 we know that 0 times 3 is
equal to 0 times 4 but it is not the
case that 3 is equal to 4 and so this is
another situation where multiplying both
sides of an equation by a variable you
can go in that direction but it's not
necessarily reversible you can't
necessarily go back in that direction
and that's why when you solve an
equation oftentimes a rational equation
by multiplying both sides of the
equation by a variable and you get a
result it's not necessarily true that
you could take that result and reverse
everything and get back to the original
equation and that's why you have to
check your extraneous solutions
especially for radical equations and
especially when you do an algebraic
operation like multiplying both sides of
an equation by a variable or by an
expression that involves a variable